[Music]
on this Sunday night the fury in Atlanta
a night of anger after a black man is
killed by police I think you've had too
much to drink what the body cam footage
reveals about the confrontation the
twister in Alberta
this is beyond the my imagination the
damage done by the spring storm the bar
brawl in Montreal why some
establishments are defying orders and
opening up and the murderer who found
redemption in math
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin in Atlanta where the death
of another black American involving
police has ignited fury once again over
a hundred protestors marched last night
outside the fast-food restaurant where
Rashard Brooks was fatally shot on
Friday demonstrators set fire to the
restaurant and shut down a major highway
dozens were arrested one officer has
been fired the police chief has stepped
down and the victim's family is calling
for justice as Jennifer Johnson reports
police have now released body cam
footage of the confrontation and a
warning this story contains disturbing
content Atlanta the site of new violent
protests a windy set on fire after a
police officer shot and killed a black
man in the restaurants parking lot 27
year old Rashard Brooks was found
sleeping in his car and the Wendy's
drive-through and then failed a sobriety
test I think you've had too much to
drink to be drivers put hands upon your
back for me the officers body camera
shows Brooks resisting arrest a struggle
ensues and the police cruiser dash cam
shows Brooks grabbing the officers taser
the audio is still recording on the
ground with the Taser the video shows
Brooks starts to run then you hear
gunshots the Georgia Bureau of
Investigation has reviewed the officers
video he runs a relatively short
distance and at that point turns around
and it appears to the eye that he points
the Taser at the Atlanta officer at that
point the Atlanta officer reaches down
and retrieves his weapon from his
holster discharges it officer Garrett
Roth has been fired officer Devon
Brosnan placed on administrative duty
and in less than 24 hours police chief
Erika shields resign Brooks family
lawyer says officers should have handled
this differently hey buddy you fell
asleep in line you okay why don't you
pull your car over there and call it
over and then do you walk over and he
can leave why is that so hard for police
officers the incident comes as emotions
in Atlanta are running high after Ahmad
Arbor II was shot to death while jogging
in February and the death of George
Floyd in Minneapolis during a police
arrest last month
Atlanta's mayor has already convened a
committee to
in the use of force by police I firmly
believe that there is a clear
distinction between what you can do and
what you should do I do not believe that
this was a justified use of deadly force
recommendations from the task force are
expected within 45 days but at lanten
say they will continue to protest until
black men don't have to fear for their
lives when stopped by police Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington a First
Nations chief in New Brunswick is asking
RCMP to stay away while his community
grieves one of their own
Rodney Levi was killed during a
confrontation with officers Friday night
police say he was shot dead after he
lunged at them with knives leaders in
the community say Levi it was troubled
but not a violent person there is
already a distrust there for the RCMP
unfortunately and this is only
solidified that scared for the
individuals here that suffer from mental
illnesses as well in addictions and they
here have what happened to a community
member people they grew up in a person
they grew up with Levi's death is the
second police-related shooting of an
indigenous person in New Brunswick this
month 26 year old Chantelle Moore died
after being shot by an officer who was
checking her well-being in Edmundston
the officer says more threatened him
with a knife a massive cleanup is
underway in southern Alberta after a
powerful storm roll through the province
thousands of homes and vehicles have
been damaged and there's a chance
another weather system could hit the
region as early as tonight Christi Dale
reports in mere minutes Calgary was
pummeled with extreme weather Saturday
evening a June thunderstorm resembling
wintertime producing hail the size of
tennis balls the hailstones hit at a
speed of up to 100 km/h ripping the
siding off homes and easily smashing out
vehicle windows I would say this is this
is beyond the
my imagination those people who are
stuck in the water in the cars it takes
a while for them to come out it was kind
of scary
many Calgary streets instantly turning
into lakes like this major Calgary
roadway flooded semi trucks and vehicles
at a standstill submerged in water the
fire department called in to save
stranded drivers drivers knee-deep in
water their vehicles unsalvageable and
near Lethbridge Environment Canada
confirmed a tornado was spotted near new
Dayton at least six other funnel clouds
were also reported in that area and by
Sunday first responders were working in
overtime pumping out water from many
Calgary streets homeowners shoveling
hail and fixing roots I'm here in Canada
also 20 years and I never saw that like
that kinds of stuff another reminder
Alberta's extreme storm season is upon
us
krista dau global news Calgary Canadian
soldiers will be heading back to Ukraine
as the military looks to restart some
overseas missions 90 Canadian Armed
Forces personnel will head back to a
military base in Ukraine where our
troops have been training Ukraine's
forces since 2015 that mission was
temporarily suspended in April because
of the pandemic the soldiers are
expected to arrive in the coming days
and spent 14 days in isolation before
training starts back up next month in
Ontario people were able to do something
today they haven't done in three months
go to church the province allowed places
of worship to open their doors on Friday
with safety measures in place but as
Jeff's simple explains not everyone is
eager to return for many church goers
this was an answer to prayer
for the first time in three months
Sunday services in Ontario were open to
in-person parishioners we are so happy
to be back
Ontario's premier gave His blessing last
week four places of worship to reopen
crowds returned for Friday prayers at
the mosque shabbat at the synagogue and
Sunday Mass a church given all the
stresses all the challenges people are
facing medically psychologically
spiritually I think now more than ever
people need the opportunity to come back
to church on reopening holy places
provinces have taken different
approaches in Quebec churches remain
closed while in BC and Alberta
gatherings must be limited to 50 people
Ontario's restrictions are more lenient
attendance numbers must be capped at 30
percent capacity this Toronto Church
seats 3000 which means they're welcoming
up to 850 people every other row is
blocked off and if you sit down you have
to be three seats away which is over two
meters but for some that's still too
close for comfort
it's simply I believe too early to open
churches this Anglican Church Deacon
says his and many other mainstream
Christian denominations are keeping
their churches closed until the fall
while streaming their services online if
we really care about individual
believers and worshipers and God's plan
that we should actually be healthy I
don't quite understand that this urge is
rushed to go back now when we still know
so little and the potential harm is so
great in the early days of the pandemic
large services were super spreaders
churches in France and South Korea
sparked outbreaks linked to thousands of
cases more than 50 members of this
Washington State Choir became infected
during a rehearsal even though they were
avoiding physical contact singing
chanting those are the kinds of
activities that from an infected person
would actually expel expel quite a bit
of virus for that reason some are taking
extra precautions this synagogue has
more than a thousand members but is
capping attendance at just 20 if we can
find ways to preserve community for me
that meant particularly reach
now two people in need for whom this can
be a lifeline
Jeff sample Global News Toronto tomorrow
Quebecers outside the Montreal region
will be able to enjoy eating out at
restaurants but bars aren't allowed to
open still some owners are determined to
open their doors as Mike Armstrong
explains they're willing to defy orders
and start pouring drinks his bar has
been closed for three months and
Counting but Steve CEO CEO says this
weekend hurts it should have been the
busiest of the year this was supposed to
be Grand Prix weekend this would be
closed here measured up in Crescent the
stage would be there would have been
beautiful beautiful
now most bars and restaurant owners in
Quebec are preparing to reopen over the
next two weeks but see osios isn't
allowed according to the government's
reopening plan only bars with food
preparation permits are supposed to
reopen if you don't have a kitchen
you're supposed to stay closed you can
have a beer or you can have a beer with
chicken wings okay it's still a bar the
government is in fact loosening the
rules for some restaurants usually
aren't allowed to sell alcohol unless
the patrons also buying food that rules
being dropped for now co-ceo says that
means restaurants are acting like bars
while he doesn't even have a date for
when he'll be able to reopen so he says
he's going to defy the government and
reopen July 1st three months I've been a
good citizen a good corporate citizen
but at some point I need to think of my
business just a few doors down is
Ziggy's pub and Ziggy I can bomb spent
Sunday preparing to reopen
he says he's run out of time and even
though he doesn't have a kitchen he's
going to open his doors July 1st I'm
opening up even if I don't love you I
have no choice I'm what my hands are
tied I can bomb says this year's a bust
he knows he's not going to make money he
just wants to get his staff back to work
and stop the bleeding I'm not asking for
anything else I'm just asking to stay
alive you're gonna have nobody left
owners could face fines if they reopen
co-ceo says he's already spoken to a
lawyer who says he's eager to fight any
fines and confident a judge would see
the rules aren't fair Mike Armstrong
Global News Montreal
coming up why Denmark and Norway are
isolating Sweden a frantic rescue
operation is underway in southeastern
China tonight after a truck carrying
liquefied natural gas exploded on a busy
highway south of Shanghai the force of
the explosion shattered windows in
nearby apartments and crushed workshops
below 19 people are dead and nearly 200
people are injured but there are fears
many victims are still buried under the
rubble
tomorrow several countries in Northern
Europe will reopen their borders to one
another but Sweden is excluded from the
plan for imposing much lighter lockdown
measures as Eric Sorenson explains the
country has found itself isolated for
what many countries have labeled a
politically fueled decision through it
all Sweden has looked more normal than
almost any country during the pandemic
with distancing guidelines and top-notch
health care the swedes defied convention
by keeping open schools for young
children and businesses like restaurants
during the first wave of kovat 19 many
Swedes are satisfied with the results
I'm not going to walking around thinking
that you know
we have veiled disasters I think this
week and I'm proud that we're not
getting much of the credit was given to
Sweden's chief epidemiologist Anders
technology that avoided a complete
lockdown it's working and this we just
have carries delivering results but it
turns out the Swedes have been
relatively hard hit Sweden has had close
to 5,000 deaths from kovat 19 the
largest number in Scandinavia for its
population that's 47 deaths per 100,000
in Sweden neighboring Denmark has had
only 10 deaths per 100,000 and Norway
just over 4 deaths per capita in Sweden
many lives were lost in long-term care
facilities acknowledging there's room
for improvement
anders technologies radio if faced with
the same disease again his country would
do something in between what Sweden did
and what the rest of the world has done
it's a disappointment for anyone who'd
hoped the Swedish model would succeed
with a softer quarantine breaks amongst
the elderly
resulting in very high death rate
amongst the elderly but data suggests
that the Swedish economy is suffering as
well so in that respect they fail in the
mean time Denmark and Norway plan to
open their borders on Monday to each
other and to Germany and Iceland but not
to Sweden yet Denmark estas Denmark is
in a different place from Sweden said
the Danish Prime Minister when it comes
to the coronavirus Sweden calls it a
political decision
it feels closing the border won't make
it safer our communicable experts says
that that is not a good thing for
hindering the spreading of the virus so
that's it then a political decision and
we don't want to take that political
decision because we are going to live
together also afterwards Sweden defends
the balance it has struck saying this is
a marathon not a sprint it's been right
before this busy
perfectly okay but it's very sad if the
lot of people are dying at the elderly
care homes but he shakes his head
because in the end there seems to be no
easy way out of the pandemic for Sweden
and every country the search continues
for a way to normalize life and the
economy without costing lives Erik
Sorensen Global News
still ahead how Trump and religious
groups are taking aim at same-sex
adoption the battle between religious
freedoms and equal rights is heating up
in the United States in 2018
Philadelphia ended a contract for the
state-funded religious adoption agency
that barred requests from same-sex
couples the city said it was
discrimination but the agency argues it
would violate its beliefs as regi
Cecchini explains the Trump
administration is now weighing in on the
case for thousands of people in the
United States adopting or fostering a
child as a way to expand a family but
same-sex couples face obstacles not
experienced by straight couples what
we've seen in recent years is an effort
to try to use the freedom of religion to
push back on those anti-discrimination
provisions in Philadelphia a
taxpayer-funded religious adoption
agency lost its contract when it barred
LGBTQ to couples from adopting saying it
violated their rights to freedom of
religious beliefs setting the stage for
a constitutional battle people should be
able to have whatever religious beliefs
they want and follow them in their home
the business world a 2018 study shows
21% of gay couples are raising adopted
kids compared with just 3% of straight
couples even as 11 states allow for
discrimination based on religion and any
qualified family that gets through the
rigors of background checks and
trainings and setting up their home to
be a loving welcoming home they are
qualified they are wonderful the case
has now been given a boost by the Trump
administration as it plays to its
conservative religious base with
Department of Justice arguing the United
States has a substantial interest in the
preservation of the free exercise of
religion they are weighing in on people
who do not fit the same religious
profile that they consider the correct
one religious freedom is a familiar
fight in the u.s. in 2018 the High Court
sided with the Denver area Baker who
refused services to a gay couple the
courts claimed his religion was shown
hostility something that could happen
again with the Supreme Court tilted
further to the right leaving the
American Civil Liberties Union to fear a
ruling over the issue of adoption could
have profound consequences for the more
than 400,000 children in foster care
across the country there are just not
enough families for them . . the court
is expected to hear this case in october
but it's unclear when a ruling will be
made for same-sex couples considering
adoption the fear is that a defense of
religious liberties will come at the
expense of their desire to grow or start
their family reggie Cecchini Global News
Washington
up next the convict earned academic how
math is helping one man find a second
chance
it's a premise straight out of a movie
Christopher havens is receiving academic
praise for helping important research
havens taught himself math in prison the
convict is serving a 25 year sentence
for murder and as Amanda jela wiki
reports he says he's using knowledge to
find Redemption and not just for himself
congratulations John is the achievement
of a lifetime the film A Beautiful Mind
tells the story of John Nash a brilliant
American mathematician who suffered from
paranoid schizophrenia many accomplished
mathematicians worked through calamities
Alan Turing helped solve the Enigma code
but was condemned for homosexuality a
very difficult life may seem there is
always something you can do and Stephen
Hawking worked through excruciating
physical disabilities and Hollywood has
given us the story of Good Will Hunting
the young man with anger issues working
as a janitor at MIT solving complex math
problems in his spare time well there's
a story playing out inside a Washington
state prison that seems equally
improbable this is Christopher havens
he's a high school dropout and former
drug addict serving 25 years for murder
in the shooting death of a Washington
man over a drug dispute now he's proving
to be a brilliant self-taught
mathematician helped me to grow into
this new individual that's why I love
mathematics right I feel like it has
offered me another chance at life Havens
story starts in solitary confinement
seven years ago the beds of cold
concrete slab in the large fluorescent
light directly above your head it
doesn't shut off
most people don't handle it too well
some people snap myself
played Sudoku Sudoku inspired him to
start learning math on his own
eventually he contacted a math journal
searching for a mentor he was put in
touch with two professors from the
University of Turin their daughter
teaches at McGill University the really
surprising thing was to realize that she
was not one of these cranks but she
actually was really gifted for math and
that he was completely self-taught
so Rudy's father eventually welcomed
Havens onto his research team the team
recently had their work published in the
prestigious math journal second chances
are so important because you never know
what will be thrown away without these
second chances I think it's a story of
transformation right so we can learn
that people can really transform their
lives we can not ever say this is a bad
guy
havens helped establish a prison math
program helping other inmates he
considers that his path to redemption
know everything she was dedicated to
victim of my crime and his family I
never I never expected my best to be
repaid but I start to what he hopes is a
better life for himself and for others
Amanda della wiki Global News Montreal
and that is global national for this
Sunday I'm Robin Gill tonight we leave
you with a special drive i birthday
celebration for Canada's youngest
centenarian yogya some boolean turned a
hundred today 70 cars honked their horns
in his honor as he sat smiling and
waving outside Toronto's Armenian
Evangelic Church where many say he
hasn't missed a Sunday service since
arriving in Canada from Lebanon 40 years
ago
thank you for watching Donna Friesland
is back tomorrow good night
[Music]